- [Instructor] The goal of this video
is to help us visualize what's
going on with the solution
at a microscopic really
at a molecular level.
And also to get practice
drawing these types
of visualizations, because
you might be asked to do so,
depending on the type of
chemistry class you're in.
So what I have here are three
different aqueous solutions,
which means that the solute
is dissolved in water.
The first one is sodium chloride.
Then we have magnesium chloride.
Then we have C12-H22-O11,
which in other words is sucrose.
And each of them are dissolved in water.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna try to
do a drawing of what's
happening at a particulate level
in the respective
rectangles right below them.
So, first of all,
let's do think about what
happens with sodium chloride.
So the first thing that you might realize,
is that sodium chloride,
this is an ionic compound.
It's made of up of a
sodium positively charged
ion or cation,
and a chloride negatively charged ion.
And if I wanna draw them,
and they're going to be
in a one to one ratio.
For every sodium there's one chloride.
And I could think about
their relative sizes
and to help us do so I'll
get out the periodic table
of elements, and we can
see here that they're both
in the third period.
And if we were just looking at the atom,
a sodium atom versus a chlorine atom,
the general trend is
as you go to the right
and you have more electrons
in that outer most shell,
the radius tends to actually get smaller.
So a chlorine atom is actually smaller
than a sodium atom but we're
not talking about atoms.
We're talking about ions.
So positively charged sodium
ion that has lost an electron.
So it actually has an electron
configuration of neon,
while the chloride anion has
an electron configuration of argon.
So it actually turns out
that the chloride anion,
is going to be larger
than the sodium cation.
And so what I will do is I will represent
the chloride anion looking like this.
I'll put a negative charge there,
and for the positively
charged sodium cation,
I will make it a little bit smaller,
something like that.
And if I wanted to visualize
it for every sodium
positively charged ion.
I would also have to
draw a chloride anion.
So that's one of them.
And then you might say,
"okay, well that's the solute,
but where is..."
And sometimes they actually
just ask you just to draw
the solute in which
case you would be done.
But if you're wondering,
well how is that
interacting with the water?
And this will even help us
understand what's happening.
Why sodium chloride,
why ionic compounds
dissolve well into water.
Well then we have to
draw the water molecules.
And if we still wanna get
the relative sizing right,
we can go back to our
periodic table of elements.
And we know that the sodium cation,
has an electron configuration of neon,
and oxygen is pretty cool close to that.
And when we're talking about water,
the oxygen atom is hogging the electrons.
The electrons are spending
a little bit more time
around the oxygen than
around the hydrogens.
So it's actually going
to be similar in size,
and oxygen and water and a sodium cation.
And obviously these aren't
going to be exact drawings,
but we can imagine each water
might look something like that.
So it's an oxygen with two hydrogens.
I'll just do it all in this
white color, right over here.
And then the question is what
would their orientation be?
And that's really important to get right,
especially when you're dealing with water,
which is a polar molecule.
We know that the electrons spend more time
around the oxygen.
We talked about this in many videos.
So the oxygen end has a
partial negative charge,
while the hydrogen ends have
a partial positive charge.
And so the orientation of
a water molecule is that
the partially negative oxygen end,
will be attracted to the positive ions.
And then the positively
charged hydrogen ends
will be attracted to the negative ions.
So you might have something like that.
That's oxygen and then the two hydrogens.
You might have an oxygen,
and then you have the two hydrogens.
Because the hydrogens,
that end of the water molecule has
a partially positive charge.
They're going to be attracted
to this chloride anion.
You might have once again,
the two hydrogens and then the oxygen.
And once again, the oxygen
is going to be attracted
to the sodium, the positively
charged sodium cations.
And I could keep filling these in for,
in this entire space.
But I think you get the
idea of what the water
would kind of look like and
how it would be oriented.
Now for these next two,
let's just focus on the solutes.
What would the solute
look like in the solution?
Well, magnesium chloride,
this once again is an ionic compound.
And so it is going to disassociate
into its constituent ions
for every one magnesium ion,
actually going to have a plus two charge.
You're going to have two,
negatively charged chloride anions.
And what's the relative sizing?
Well, to help us with that,
we go back to the periodic
table of elements.
And if we're talking
about a magnesium two plus
or positively charged ion,
it's still going to have an
electron configuration of neon,
and it's going to have more
protons than the sodium ion.
So it's gonna pull even harder on them.
So it's gonna be even
smaller than the sodium ion.
So we could draw the
magnesium ions like this.
Maybe I'll do two of them.
So I'm gonna do it even
smaller than the sodium
and I'll write two plus,
because it has a positive two charge.
I will write two plus again,
'cause it has a positive charge.
And for every one of those,
you're going to have two chloride anions.
So maybe one there, maybe one there,
maybe one there and then maybe one there.
And then if you were
asked to draw the solvent,
draw the water, you would
orient it similarly.
Where the partially
positive the hydrogen ends
of the water would be attracted to
the negative chloride anions.
And the oxygen end of the water
molecules would be attracted
to these plus two charge magnesium ions.
Now what about sucrose?
It isn't an ionic compounds.
So in this situation,
it's not going to disassociate.
So a sucrose molecule
is relatively larger.
I'll draw it like that.
Maybe we have another one just like that.
And the reason why it
dissolves in water well is,
a sucrose molecule has
parts of the molecule
that have polarity to it.
It has a lot of OH groups.
So there's parts of the molecule
that are partially positive
and other parts of the molecule
that are partially negative,
other parts that are partially positive.
And so that's able to be
attracted to the various ends
depending on whether
it's partially positive,
partially negative,
of the water molecule.
And so I'll just write it like this.
C12-H22-O11.
For the sake of time,
I haven't drawn the water molecules here
and to actually make, to
draw them intelligently,
you would have to know what
parts of this larger molecule
have a partially positive
or partial negative charge.
But as we'll see the
fact that you can either
disassociate into ions
that clearly have charge,
or then you have a larger
molecule where parts of it
have a partial charge or have some charge
associated with it.
That's what allows it to dissolve well
into a polar solvent like water.